having a world record is a pretty great
achievement
having a world record that's
mathematically unbeatable
is even better today i'm going to show
you some world record
surfaces which are part of the field of
algebraic geometry
and that topic is really a way to
connect equations
with the beautiful shapes that they
correspond to
mathematicians have always been eager to
visualize their work
and get an idea of what an equation
looks like
without computers around they went to
great lengths to
calculate lots of values and used
plaster
wire and paper to hand craft those
models
world record surfaces are particularly
baffling shapes that stand out because
of their number of singularities
i'll get to what that means in just a
bit but first
let's take a look at how an equation
forms any shape at all
this is a free program called surfer
derived from the word surface
there's a link to it down in the
description it allows us to visualize
the shapes from equations in real time
more precisely those equations are
polynomials in the three variables
x y and z we don't have to worry about
logarithms roots or negative exponents
here
algebraic geometry cares about
sufficiently nice equations
let's take a look at the equation x
squared plus y
squared plus z squared minus one is
equal to zero
having pythagoras in mind the solution
here
are just those points that are a
distance of one from the origin
and indeed we can see a perfect sphere
on our screen if i rotate the sphere
around you can't even notice
this is because of its perfect symmetry
and we can see that this symmetry
is anchored in the equation already we
do the same thing to
x y and z which is raising the variable
to the power of two
and adding them all up we can't
distinguish between the variables
in terms of mathematical operations so
we wouldn't expect to see
anything unsymmetric in this picture but
let's try and break the symmetry
we can keep x squared plus y squared
and just write minus z squared
so we still can't differ between x and y
but something should happen in the z
direction
and lucky enough that's exactly what we
see
this double cone is still symmetric in
the x and y directions
but we see a different story when we
look up and down
but there is something else going on
here you can see that
very spiky point in the middle well this
is what we refer to
as a singularity
if the first thing that pops into your
mind upon hearing the word singularity
is a black hole or the movie
interstellar then you're on a great path
to becoming a physicist in more abstract
mathematics this term
could mean a lot of different things and
usually describes points where something
interesting happens
it is more than good enough for this
video to keep thinking of that double
cone intersection
when you hear the word singularity for
those of you eager for a more technical
definition
these points have vanishing partial
derivatives
now how do these singularities relate to
the world records we spoke about before
well it wouldn't really make sense to
just try and find the most amount of
singularities
because there wouldn't really be a limit
instead what is quite a natural question
is to ask how many singularities can you
find
for a given degree of a polynomial
equation
the degree just counts how many
variables get multiplied together
in each term of the equation for example
the degree of our sphere or our double
cone
would be two since two variables get
multiplied in the terms
the degree of x times y times z
equals zero would therefore be three if
two terms have different amounts of
those variables
the degree would be the bigger number so
x
squared times y times z plus z squared
has a degree of four and so on
as it turns out the double cone is
already a world record surface itself
as it turns out that you cannot have
more than one singularity
for degree two but what about higher
degrees
mathematicians ask themselves this exact
question for
centuries and yet we still only know the
exact number of singularities
up to degree six so there are still lots
of records
still to be snatched out there and it
might just be one of you watching now
who gets one mathematicians have been
able to sort of sandwich
the maximal number of singularities a
surface of a given degree
could have via examples for the lower
bound
and some more abstract arguments for the
upper bound
and it's finally time to get to the star
of this video
a surface of degree 6 simply called a
sextick
that cannot be bettered the bath sextic
[Music]
six is currently the highest degree for
which an unbeatable record exists
and the history of this surface is quite
interesting
it's a surface that really shouldn't be
possible
here are two research papers by
well-known italian mathematicians
one from 1946 and one from 1982
they both went through a thorough review
process for the reputable journals they
were published in
the older paper claims that the maximum
number of singularities
for a sex stick is 52 while
the other one claims it is 64.
yet they are both wrong they're wrong
because the bath sextig
published in 1996 16 years
after the second paper actually has 65
singularities
one is quick to think that something
mathematically proven
would outlast any debate however
since we're human after all we consider
a
mathematical proof correct if we don't
find any mistakes in it
in the same year as bath introduced his
new shape to the world
two other researchers proved that 66
singularities wasn't possible making
bath's record unbeatable
at least if there are no mistakes this
time
[Music]
so let's first take a look at the
equation for the sparth sextech
it is said to enclose in its symmetric
frame
many hundred years of geometrical
insight and skill
we can see that the first part has three
factors that are quadratic
in the variables hence we have a term of
degree six there
ignoring phi which is a constant the
second term
looks familiar we just have the formula
of our sphere
squared and multiplied with some other
number
the mysterious number phi in this
equation is actually the famous golden
ratio
if you are somewhat baffled that this
number makes an appearance here
then you are no different than me and if
you're unaware what the golden ratio is
there's a link with more information in
the description below
so at first glance the golden ratio
shouldn't have anything to do with the
singularities we are concerned about
here
but to understand why it is here we can
dive into the construction of bath
sextic
what was he thinking about whilst
constructing this now very famous
surface
well probably about symmetry and some
ancient platonic solids
these regular polygons have been known
since antiquity
and are classified as platonic solids
they are highly symmetric so take a look
at the dodecahedron for example
if we were to rotate it a little bit a
certain way
it looks exactly like it did before
another
reason why we might find these solids so
aesthetically pleasing
might be their deep relation to the
golden ratio
in this colorful picture you can see
this relation displayed nicely
the golden ratio pops up almost every
time when a lot of regularity is
involved
as in the regular pentagons on screen
right now
since regular polygons are what make up
the faces of platonic solids
imagining a connection between the
famous ratio
and the solids doesn't seem so
far-fetched anymore
this isosahedron has six symmetry planes
if we multiply all of those planes
together
we get the starting point of the bath
sex stick
we can see this shape and surfer as well
these are the six
symmetry planes that you saw before they
all look like discs
because surfer clips big infinite
surfaces
by a sphere in order to display them
this is not yet what bath sex it looks
like though
what he did was to subtract a sphere
from these planes
to construct the singularities and you
can see
a little slider on the side the reason
this is here
is because bath hasn't actually just
created one sex stick
but instead a whole family of them
depending on this little parameter
a and when playing around with it we can
see the shape
change in real time if it is just right
some new singularities appear and there
it
is the world record surface as it turns
out
this parameter a has to be deeply
connected to the golden ratio
and only then will you get the full 65
singularities the setup we chose here
just shows a from 0 to 1.
we can zoom in and out change colors
and play around with the parameter a now
if you were able to count all of these
double points here
you might notice that there are only 50
singularities
and you might wonder what's going on
since there are supposed to be
65 well we're only able to see 50 of
them
because the other 15 singularities
are hiding at infinity but
maybe what that means can be a topic for
another time
a cute thing to realize is that the
shape of the dodecahedron
is in the sex stick we can see that
each of the singularities actually fall
on a vertex
of that platonic shape but perhaps that
is actually less of a surprise
now that we know how bath's surface was
constructed
the shape also has radial symmetry in
some sense
due to the subtraction of the sphere i
have here a
3d printed bath sex stick it's not the
version with all
65 singularities as that would be pretty
unstable
and this was hard enough to print as it
was but if you do have access to a 3d
printer there's also a link to this
template
down in the description and this leaves
us with the future
the best we can do for a polynomial of
degree 7
is 99 singularities but there might be a
surface
out there of degree 7 with 100
singularities
all it takes is a curious mind to find
it
and that search may start with a lesson
on brilliant
brilliant have kindly sponsored this
video so let's take a look at their quiz
on platonic solids
part of their course on 3d geometry
they start by asking how many faces
could possibly meet at a single vertex
of a three-dimensional shape if all of
those faces
are squares well a cube is such a shape
and if you look at the corner you'll see
that three faces
are able to meet at that vertex so we
can plug in our answer as
three two squares would only fold to
make a flat
shape and the four squares cannot meet
at a single vertex
because there's no space to be able to
fold them up
now there are lots of shapes where every
vertex is identical
such as the ones in the pictures here
but we want to consider
these shapes with identical vertices
that are also
made out of only a single kind of
regular polygon
so their faces are either all squares or
all triangles or all
some regular shape and the shapes with
these properties
are called platonic solids what is the
largest
number of sides a regular polygon can
have
if three of them meet at a single vertex
this one's a little tricky but the
correct answer is five
a five-sided shape the pentagon is the
most that can fit on a single vertex
if you look at the picture that leaves a
little bit of room to be able to fold it
up
but with the hexagons they fit together
perfectly
leaving no room to be able to fold them
and with the heptagons which is
seven sides or anything with more sides
than that
can't share a vertex because their
angles will add to more than 360 degrees
and you can see you've got that little
gap left in there that can't be filled
the next question is which of the
following nets
of equilateral triangles can fold up
successfully
to make a vertex of a three-dimensional
figure
a won't work because it would just fold
over on itself
and e doesn't really work either unless
you want your shape to have a concave
part
however all the others can fold to make
a vertex
and so putting it all together we've
found that there are three ways to make
a three-dimensional vertex using the
equilateral triangles
those are the ways we just saw and
there's only one way to make a vertex
using the squares
that was that three-sided intersection
and we know that a five-sided shape is
the maximum that you'd be able to use to
make a vertex at all
so there are exactly five ways to
arrange regular polygons
around a single vertex to form a net
that will fold
into a three-dimensional shape and for
all five of these cases for the vertices
they can be extended to make the full
shape where every vertex is identical
that gives us the five platonic solids
the tetrahedron
the cube the octahedron the dodecahedron
and the isosahedron and this course goes
on to explore
how to think about paths that travel
through or on the faces
of these polyhedra if you would like to
try out brilliant for yourself and
explore the rest of the course
you can head to brilliant.org tibby's
and that link will be on screen and down
in the description
thank you to brilliant and also thank
you to my patreon supporters
who have made this video possible a
special shout out to today's patreon cat
of the day
phoenix
you